[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we're gonna ask the
question how do we park how do we party
man and we're gonna answer that question
for you and specifically what we mean by
that because it was how do you party but
what's intended to be a little bit you
know clickbait tea because I mean who we
tried to kid here we wanted you to click
those of you that need that kind of
motivation we're talking about
specifically is the way that we approach
the Hollywood interest
industry for free Endres tree party
scene which we have become somewhat
familiar with this year we're starting
well we're starting to become familiar
with it the one the one party that I
think we're gonna spend a lot of time on
was it was the GQ part late that was
late last year yeah it was not this year
technically so yeah there's there was
that party there was a golden clothes
part we just haven't had an opportunity
to like fully process with you our
experience of these parties and it it is
a whole world in and of itself not just
the party but the I mean this whole
aspect of the industry well it's a part
of it so I you know the goal of this
episode is just to share with you our
experience warts and all I don't think
there'll be that many warts yes there
are I just want to have fun talking
about it because it's some some of the
more hilarious things that have happened
in your presence have happened at these
parties I don't know and I don't know if
I'm if I'm fully ready to go I'm ready
the world you can watch know about it
but I trust you uh ear biscuit ear with
don't trust me with we trust that you
will keep all of this in confidence with
my experience yeah because it's we also
we we did share that one story about
the party we were at where we couldn't
get a drink yeah at the bar and then you
know I was on a previous podcast I don't
know which one it was
I think he's I think that guy's still
thinking about probably not making us a
drink and that is just kind of like a
small indication of what our subsequent
experiences have been now I'm gonna
start with what I think is a a maxim a
thesis of what okay of why course she
could just say it's a hypothesis no it's
not all the way no it's not hypothesis
it is a maxim from which or a principle
from which all of the stuff in all of
the reasons that we're gonna talk about
why we even do this yeah why it exists
and that is because I'm gonna try to
make it sound like a maximum that some
maximum Maxim that which fuels Hollywood
is bullish yeah that is the maximum okay
yeah and what I mean by that is that if
you were you talk about the Hollywood
machine now let's say the Hollywood
Machine is a vehicle and you were to
look into the gas tank and you were like
what fuels this Hollywood machine and I
am and the premise is you open up the
gas cam and it's full of bull or I would
say it might be a vapid tank of
emptiness well no I think that's the
destination that's the that is what your
soul but that is the destination of the
Hollywood Machine is a vast tank of
emptiness but the the fuel is both and
here's and here's what I'm saying is
that every single you know you want to
believe you want to believe that all
this is based on art and talent and not
and obviously those things exist you you
you need to be good at what you're doing
to kind of get into into some extent to
kind of get into the game at all at all
and then you might add to that okay yeah
it's also who you know but because we're
all humans and but you might you might
be thinking that that's portable
I think it goes further because that I'm
including that knowing people and like
getting things done with people that you
know or that you you know someone who
knows someone and you fit you feel like
there's a little bit more trust or
there's something like I owe this person
that that's that's true of just life in
a lot of ways so I think that what
you're getting at goes even further than
that to this just you you you want to
start to think that like oh there's
people in Hollywood and they're going to
parties and they're all having a great
time and just hanging out and the people
who are at parties are popular and if
you're so if you are seen at a party
then you are seen as popular as hot as
as the cool crowd I mean it's like
there's this high school cool crowd
thing that happens and it's a whole game
built around like the whole TMZ pictures
being taken voyeuristic Entertainment
Tonight or situation it's all about it's
all about perception and the reality is
superseded by the perception and the
perception determines the reality in a
lot of ways yes that's in this town
right now let me say that I'm not
critiquing that this podcast is not
about critiquing that obviously can has
been well critiqued and I think that we
navigate the the space knowing the at
least being somewhat familiar with the
pitfalls of like thinking that this is
where ultimate purpose belongs we don't
that's not what we believe and so we
kind of play this game no one trying to
figure out the rules but knowing that
the vast tank of emptiness at the end of
the rainbow is not something that we're
interested in but what we are interested
in is we're interested in exercising our
craft right that's what we're trying to
do and we want to do that on the most
significant level possible and
so that's kind of our purpose in in what
we do and why we're playing this game
right we play the game because we want
to continue to create and we want to be
able to create in the most significant
way and the best and most strategic way
to do that for us is to do it in the
context of the system it at least some
what we are now we're doing a lot that
we're very proud of and that we're very
glad to continue to be doing in this
alternate reality that came from the
internet right and you know so without
sacrificing any of that you know we
still want to make a movie we still want
to make another scripted story a
scripted series that is seen by more
people than buddy system season two to
date has been seen by so right we start
to say how can we do we need to start
putting you know getting in the ring and
playing this game well let me need to
buy a ticket to the game and start
playing it well let me just address to
get some opportunity address one
criticism which I relate to and
appreciate because there's a lot of
people who make digital content like us
and independent creators who make
digital content you know everything we
do on YouTube this podcast all the stuff
that we do independently we can cancel
ourselves we determine when the season
starts and ends that's completely
outside of the hollywood machine in a
lot of ways right so you might say well
why don't you just continue to create in
that sphere you guys could just make a
movie you guys could go on Kickstarter
and raise money from mythical beasts and
just make a movie yes that is a path and
we're not saying we'll never do that but
in the current situation that we find
ourselves in the most yeah you can put
that on airplane mode because you know
we might as well be on an airplane right
now the most the way to get your work to
be considered by the people who kind of
control the cultural conversation is you
know it's very very difficult to say
make a movie completely outside the
system and just sell it directly to
people who already know you and for that
to be as significant and I don't know
maybe you
maybe we'll learn X number of years down
the road that we should just not even
pursued this but for what for better or
worse what we are pursuing right now is
trying to create things on a higher
level and do it with at least a portion
of what we're doing as part of our
career within the system so and so you
hire a PR firm to help you navigate and
give to you opportunities and get you in
the stuff right so we so we're we're
doing that and that's how you get into
these parties before you become like a
bigger star in their eyes in Oracle who
are throwing the parties before the
people throwing the parties want you to
be at the parties which was not where
we're at right now right you have to
find somebody who can get you into the
parties right it's again and that's not
right there's a little dirty wind it's
like you know we're saying that involves
money but the funny that I mean I'm just
well yeah you got when you get
indirectly but yeah yeah but the the
interesting thing just to give you a
small example of this so the structure
of a lot of these parties is that you
you show up at the event and there is a
red carpet you get your picture taken by
a series of photographers you've seen
these we share those photos and we try
to do our little stance the handshake
stance and stuff like that but one of
the things I noticed pretty early on is
that we went to a few of these parties
last year and that's all the same
photographers I mean it's these people
who are there's a small there's a
relatively small pool of people right
and so it's just like like you can hear
them they're like who are these guys and
then we have to say let's rhett and Link
and last what are your last means well
don't worry about our last names can you
stand could you stand on that side no we
stand like this we stand like rhett and
Link like there was a lot of orientation
for people to understand what we were
trying to do and then little by little
you start hearing people say I actually
heard a photographer say oh it's those
guys again and it's in its marking sadly
bored of us already sadly oh it's those
guys
again is what we're looking for right so
the people who put your they're gonna
shake hands and then raise their one of
their legs there they go they're doing
that dumb pose again so and why that is
part of it I'm just saying that that is
part of the it's one of the biggest
parts this game before you even get into
the party you got to do this and matter
of fact you could just stop there
because it's such an important part of
the party you could make an argument and
I think many celebrities do in their own
mind they show up for the red carpet and
then they just leave and don't even go
to the party because they got their
picture taken
proof that they were there because the
game or at least a big aspect of it is
looking like you belong with the cool
people say oh this is a cool thing
here's a picture of that person at it
that's it
I would I can prove our I'm in the group
I'm in the group yeah I got my picture
in the same place that these other like
Jeff Goldblum got his picture right and
then then you go into the party after
that and you're like okay yeah like 90
percent of this is done it's like you
because you got your picture you got
your credit but and so the way that we
approach these these parties though and
this is what we're gonna get into isn't
it it's not the we obviously we do the
red carpet thing we get the picture
so we'll be a so so somebody who writes
something on the internet will associate
us with this particular event but of
course we approach it you know it yeah
we K we maybe we may have a show that's
very popular in certain circles and and
that we may have some stuff to show and
and some stuff to be able to say hey we
should be here I mean we've created this
and that but what we're kind of the
overarching thing that we're thinking
when we're there is really the sort of
the perspective of like 13 year old
rhett and Link you know yeah Buies Creek
Elementary School is it's it's like
there's a lot of famous people here who
do you want to talk to you know really
right how good is the food where where
is the food how much is it
how bigger the plate well there's two
things going there's learning the game
which is uh you know it's it's just a
it's a challenge that in trying to
figure out how this game is played and
you know how do you get points and how
do you advance your strategy and all
those things that's interesting
observing it as an outsider is very
entertaining to us I believe oh yeah and
hence why we're happy to talk about it
but then there's also an aspect of it
that is you know then you're actually
you're trying to get to know people
there is another part of the game that
is getting to know people that are
successful at getting things done
and making connections because it is
that who you know and who you met and
when you met him was how was their
breath cuz do you like them do you want
to keep working with them or how is
their brother you know that type of
stuff because it that they're just
humans to says humans working with
humans so you got to work that part of
it but then the question in my mind and
this will become painfully obvious once
we get into that what happened is man
why is it worth it there's turns out
there's a lot of risk involved in going
in trying to play this game there's a
risk of oh there's risk when you play
this type of emotional if not which is
physical injury emotional injury
embarrassment man it really does feel a
lot of times like it's your first day in
high school walking around the cafeteria
with your lunch tray trying to figure
out who do you sit with or who do you
sit next to and is there gonna be an
open seat at all or somebody gonna come
in am I gonna trip and fall and boy the
risk is real I'll just I'll just leave
it at that for the moment but um yeah
and hopefully unpack entertaining to you
but before we get into the stories we do
want to let you know that you can grab a
hat we got you know that they're calling
these dad hats it's is what the youths
are into these days we've we've got a
tan one we've got a black one with a
mythical logo on
the rand ler nice link the one that you
have on has some like actual metal
buttons on the side this is nice
workmanship there's leather straps in
the back yes you can get that also we
are selling at amazon.com slash mythical
we are selling the blu-ray yes this is
still a thing this is still a technology
there are still blu-ray player I'm going
to call this a collector's item the tour
mythicality live in Los Angeles yeah so
that was when we recorded the entire
tour obviously it's available you know
on other platforms like iTunes but you
can get the the physical thing the
physicality of the tour of mythicality
yeah and there's a disc inside of that
for those of you who don't understand
what blu-ray is it's a disc you take
that round thing you insert it not into
your mouth but into a blu-ray player and
then it's a video that will play it's
just nice to have even if you never want
there's like a menu at the take an click
on different options it's very advanced
basically defines you know our
adolescent years or at least amazon.com
slash mythical Anders mythical dot store
get it okay so do you want to talk about
the GQ party yeah let's talk about them
in chronological order because I think
there's things that we learned that then
the question with the Golden Globes
party is or any of those lessons then
applied I think somewhere I think is
that's one of the one of the main
questions and plus I just want to get
this whole GQ experience I just want to
cleanse it from my system but so put it
on the internet it's gonna hurt it might
hurt a little bit but at least it'll be
out of me and on to you okay so I can
talk a little bit about the philosophy
of how we operated these parties okay so
well Stevie was with us so yeah well yes
that's part of it so that's the first
she was with us that one Stevie went
with us to the GQ party which you know I
think there's a different dynamic when
it's is there's a different dynamic when
it
two guys walking around the party like
they're like we had at the Golden Globes
HBO party then when you've got sort of
three people two guys and a girl cuz now
you kind of seem like this is a group
and at any time that you just begin
talking to each other you just look like
people who are a group of people talking
but two guys talking to each other yeah
doesn't a conjugation a group really
right specially when they both have on
tuxes and look obviously your friends in
the way that we were kind of in a go
yeah they're not talking to anyone
except who they came with with three
there's a question right that's it
that's good and you know I'm gonna
before we before we before we expose
link a little bit I'm going to build him
up a little bit because link between the
two of us is the one who is more
fearless and just beginning to talk to
somebody right he's always been the one
that would go up to somebody kind of
initiate a conversation
I'm very standoffish in like
self-conscious and don't like to don't
like to do that I don't ever talk to
celebrities when I see Emmy but if I'm a
fan I
but link is very comfortable with that
it leads to some great opportunities and
some some great mishaps it is I mean it
the whole point is to talk to people to
get to know people at a party know it's
great and so what it is very difficult
to talk to people I mean again it goes
back to that whole like you're in high
school and you're like you don't know
anybody in the cafeteria and you're like
to make your way you got to start
meeting people and there is a pecking
order
yeah well it's like no but not mean
who's gonna come up and talk to us right
well in into I kind of contrast it so
and so obviously it's one of those
things that like this is this is like
life advice right so when you are with
somebody who has a particular strength
just let them do that thing right don't
yeah I haven't absolutely I don't it
does I don't care at all that he's the
one like if if link and I are helping
someone move for instance well you know
what links gonna do he's gonna be the
one that is in the moving truck
organizing and tetra Singh the stuff
into the moving truck yeah and you're
gonna be eating whatever food they
provide
now and I got a bad back and Ike you
know and so where your doughnuts not
only is he good at that but he likes to
do that let someone use their gifts so
when we go to a party together I'm like
all right
like when I went to I went to the Queer
Eye for the straight guy premiere party
with my wife just the two of us yeah
she's a big fan of the show I am sort of
a proximate fan of the show through her
mm-hm
and have watched it with her a few times
and we really wanted to talk to some of
the cast but she's Jonah to lock a queer
ah she's just with Yura she's just like
me in that she doesn't she's just she's
feel like I don't want to look stupid I
don't wanna be embarrassed
so we ended up talking like we only
talked to people that we had like she
saw Nate Berkus you know the designer
and she had a point of connection and
she had something and they've been to
the same anyway she talked to him for a
second and that was like cool and that
worked and this is people but we didn't
end up actually having a conversation
with any of the cast because at some
point they ended up just hanging out
with John Legend and Chrissy Teigen and
right just in this group and it was like
it was impenetrable
I actually went up to the group because
Lance Bass was on the outside of the
group and I told Jessi I was like I bet
that Lance Bass knows who I am I'm just
I was going out on a limb but I was like
he's done a bunch of stuff with
youtubers so you hovered around Lance
Bass member of what NSYNC
is it NSYNC and then I waited for him to
turn around in memory wrecking ball no
that's not what I did what I did is I
was like I'm gonna go up to Lance Bass
and initiate a conversation and then I
will figure out he I will know instantly
if he knows who I am if he does I'm on
the exterior of the circle and I might
be able to do a flip or switcheroo and
suddenly be on the inside body slam now
you got to understand this took a lot
this took a lot for me I went up to
Lance Bass and I said hey Lance I'm
Rhett and he was like cool cool or
something like that and continued to
sort of Bob his head to the music he was
waiting to get in on
the other convo and I want you to block
him from it yeah and I think I said
something else but it was I I you know I
had an out plan I don't movement it was
but I took the out I pulled the ripcord
real soon
real early total fail so I've been there
too bud
yeah and we talked about this so then I
knew going into this party I'm like all
right I'm gonna I'm the tip of the spear
I'm that you know I'm gonna gonna stab
around and then once I plunge into some
flesh then you guys are gonna run in and
say oh I'm sorry this is my spear let me
yank that out and let's have a
conversation that was the stated plan
this mean we were all on the same the
plan the the plan was that you would
start the conversation and that we would
then come in and continue the
conversation but the sort of unforeseen
thing that didn't happen is we didn't
discuss any of the parameters for how
you would begin a conversation right and
why would you do that that's my and
that's kind of the lessons that we added
up learning well like I said there's a
pecking order so you go in there and I
mean it's you know it to initiate a
conversation with somebody that is known
and famous you are immediately saying it
is a position of weakness and of your
your lower because your Emmy and it's
kind of like well are you are you a fan
or are you another person that I should
think is cool there's some psychological
stuff happening and and not just that
but the percentage is the breakdown of
like recognizable you know this sounds
again I said from the beginning the
premises that the fuel of Hollywood
machine is bullet so we're going with
that for a second the percentage of
people who are quote unquote famous you
know the celebrities is a minority very
low at this party the majority of people
at the party are industry people who
have a connection to that to the brand
or the company
the people who are putting the party on
and so this isn't like in which we've
never been to a kind of party where like
you go to like a celebrity's home and
every single person there is a celebrity
that's a different that's like a private
party we you've never been invited to
one of those no but this is the kind of
thing where if you're a celebrity you
know that there's a bunch of regular
fault
who want to start a conversation with
you so all the celebrities have a little
bit of a defensive mechanism well
they're operating with we got then we
looked around and we didn't see any
big-time celebrities and we knew they
were gonna be at this party so we
immediately are like asking like is
there a hidden room is there like a we
let you make a quick lap or you're
looking around you realized is there is
there like a roped off section and we
actually talked we knew the you know the
people from GQ who were throwing the
party and then we were we were talking
with them and yet we asked them like ask
them so where's the horses special
where's the real famous room that's like
oh there isn't what I'm saying okay all
right and then I looked around and I saw
Adam from Adam ruins everything yes we'd
never met but we both worked with the
same producing partners before and so we
he came from the internet college humors
oh you're just we kind of go in with
some confidence thinking we probably are
familiar with each other well I felt
like we were in similar places on the
pecking order so anyone could approach
anyone he's walking by and I'm like hey
Adam
I'm Linc good to meet you good to
finally meet you is what I said because
it's like I felt like we almost have
crossed paths a lot good that was good
he was very user friendly he ended up
talking to us for a while he was you
know we were it was familiar with our
work we were familiar with his work we
were it was mutual adulation we were on
the level okay
great start it was right when we walked
in we actually talked about how awkward
this place the exercise because he kind
of explained to us he's like this isn't
the first one yeah with these type of
party that I bent I don't do this
normally either so I talked about that
dynamic of pretending to belong to then
be seen as cool and lo and behold as
we're talking a photographer yeah
approaches doesn't and just starts
taking photos of us having a candid
conversation they were candid photos
candid photos and then you started
talking about how jay-z takes a candid
photo jay-z likes to laugh while a
photos are taken of him so even though
he's in a conversation where there may
not it may not have been a punch line at
the moment he sees the cameraman he just
kind of like throws his head back yeah
and it opens his mouth look a picture in
mid lap look at candid pictures of jay-z
on the internet and you will be
surprised at how many he is smiling and
laughing in all of them and I
immediately realized as he were telling
me and we were talking about that
dynamic with Adam runs everything
whoo the beauty of the genius of it
because now there's photos of jay-z
having just having the time of his life
with other people who apparently are
cool at parties so so we tried that a
little bit there may be an image
floating around as I'm laughing of of
that and it just as a side note Adam
does have a natural instinct to ruin
everything like as we were talking about
things like he he was like almost
literally biting his lip trying to not
overanalyze I think in an adorable way I
really like the guy wasn't annoying to
me I was actually fascinating that like
we were analyzing this party situation
and he was like breaking it down like
that's literally how his brain works oh
he was he was doing actually like
well-informed version of what we're
trying to do right now
he was pointing out all the you know the
dynamics of the situation and seeing
right right through it but we knew if we
kept talking to him that we wouldn't
accomplish much because I mean we we
both felt like we're on the same level
and we needed to make a few laps and
we're like if this falls apart if we
don't generate any other leads let's
meet back here and have a good time
I think I said that one point so I think
I want to cover the sort of the first
misfire okay well who is that that's the
you know that guy okay I'm doing it in
order I'm doing it order as well I did
see Joe Keary before that the guy from
strange okay was on our show yeah and I
went up and talked to him and he
remembered me because he was on the show
and then his girlfriend was with him and
she is from I was like I was talking to
them for a while and I didn't know who
she was and I was like it follows and I
was like and what
you do she's like I'm an actress I'm
like anything I wouldn't know and they
were like it follows and I'm like
haven't seen that yeah that's so so then
that got a little bit you asked that
question but you typically as someone
who never watches anything you shouldn't
say anything I would know because that's
a really small pool of things well
that's her fault yeah so you should be
like oh cool
what what are you working on now right
remember that's a so we definitely Jacob
almost fell out of his seat we yeah that
that was something that we gleaned once
we talked about this later because I
kept going I kept going to talk about
what that people were known for to
lessons learned and that we already
learned with the joke Yuri conversation
first of all Joe was incredibly gracious
and he's like you know he's done this
with the with the with the the way the
strangers things kind of blew up and now
he's gotten all these other roles like
he's like he's established himself he's
a Hollywood celebrity he can go to these
things everybody recognizes him and he
was super gracious super nice his
girlfriend was equally nice and great so
we had a good time talk to us for a
while
now you asked me I was like I was
feeling good well two but two things I
want to give the two lessons learned did
this conversation because the first one
was don't talk to them about the thing
because you also talked to Joe about Wow
stranger things season you told him
you're like yeah man I hadn't finished
season two yet like so you actually so
first of all you know I was like don't
spoil it for me but you know what maybe
you could spoil the boy cool if joke
kiri spoiled season 2 for me no it
wouldn't because rule no no that was me
talking to him rule number one I told
him that okay I wasn't there yet I see
it I didn't come in fast enough rule
number one is do not talk to a celebrity
about the thing that they are known most
for because cuz every fan because that's
what every fan does and you're trying to
establish yourself it's now I'm not a
fan I'm like you bro I'm a peer so the
question is you were on my show what are
you working on now that's the question
and then the second that's what they
want a second thing that happened is we
were up there Stevie and I joined the
conversation we're talking and about I
don't know four minutes four to five
minutes into the conversation
I got the sense I was like we should we
should exit this conversation you know I
can kind of tell that Jose I think the
proper terminology be let joke let Joe
go because he's being gracious he's got
lots of people to talk to but I don't
think that link got that message and you
continued to speak and continue to bring
things up yeah for another five minutes
really like y'all gonna joke super
gracious and so he wasn't gonna be the
one to bail because he's such a nice guy
but eventually in the pecking order you
can't monopolize someone above you he
did too much of their time he did bail
eventually so the second rule is you
have to cut the conversation if you are
you need to exit the conversation first
if you're below that person on the
pecking order so that you don't seem
like you're trying to monopolize their
time yeah sounds ugly sounds gross but
it is true and but I was kind of riding
too high at that point I was like he
remembered me it's like hey we're having
we had a fun conversation they were
laughs maybe lasts a little long didn't
know that yet and then I'm walking ahead
of you guys again I'm like I'm trolling
like a bass fisherman going through and
I like it's close quarters and so like
people are passing on the left and right
and people are a lot of people make eye
contact because they're looking for
someone who's higher on the pecking
order than them yep people want to see
somebody famous so I try to have a look
on my face that like I was famous yeah
me famous headaches because I had hair
on my head that looked famous yeah we
look like guys who are trying real hard
I mean the suit that I had on your suit
especially was trying so hard
toned down and I'm already so tall I'm
Arnie you know like a beacon it was like
a there's like a checkerboard I might as
well have had like a light on me that it
was like I'm trying hard you know like a
neon sign I didn't have that but I just
I had to look on my face and as I walked
by this couple the guy caught my eye and
I turn and I looked at him at
point-blank range like yeah I could
probably put my thumb on my nose and
then reach my pinky out and put it on
his nose
right that's pretty cool like that's
pretty close and then I was like
I recognize this guy I know exactly who
this guy is and I was like Greg and let
me just say that his name was not Greg
that's not what I knew about him
apparently I didn't know his name but I
but then I followed up with me and I was
like I could tell by the look on his
face that he was right Greg it but but
why Greg that's but that's not I was
like that's not how you begin
conversations you don't look at people
and imagine what their names might be I
did I say I knew him that never should
be that I was like uh-uh
okay your name's not Greg but I do know
who you are you are the rock climber
it was Alex Honnold and he was like I
was like so - I'm sorry just my name's
link what's your name he said Alex I'm
like yes yes so your name is Alex you
climb so this is my formation hold him
what he did with no harnesses you are a
freak of nature I didn't say that but I
was thinking your brain your body your
everything is a frickin nature he climbs
like El Capitan at Yosemite just in a
pair of shorts and a t-shirt now I saw
the cellphone I saw you with starting
this conversation and I was like this is
a good conversation like because this is
who famous this isn't somebody Lynch
everybody's gonna know about this guy
he's a climber I follow him on Instagram
I think he's absolutely amazing I do
know this name is Alex not Greg so do i
yeah you know now and so when I saw you
talking to him I was like this is great
go up I have points of reference about
who he is a photo on Instagram and so
and again I introduced you I remembered
your name and she became super nice guy
very gracious and didn't act like he
didn't have time for us at all he was in
fact I made fun of myself I knew that
like you got out of it you got out of it
it's not like you completely embarrass
yourself like and we later later and we
fully recovered right and he's super
nice and he also talked about how sure
he'd you know if he could be on the show
at some point we were like yeah you know
we there's a picture of us holding up on
Instagram we held up our hands because
his hands are like so like
the kind of hands that you need to climb
the faces of mountains and to put just a
pair of shorts we were fascinated by
super nice guy
also his girlfriend super nice super
nice I called her a Shanthi yeah that
was not everything not her name but by
then it was a joke so there my pet names
for them at that point became Greg and
Ragan ashanti and they got a real big
kick out of that one I brought it back
at the close of when we were saying
goodbye after probably talking to them
wait for way too long as well
definitely yeah that it wasn't you also
talk to them too you talk to them more
than I did but what what I keep but you
gotta be in agreement I can't be like
alright link let's go I mean like you
were like you were so zoned in that I
could what am I gonna be like pinch you
like a child on the arm I'm not gonna do
that we could work something out well
well what we did is right after that I
told you I was like you gotta get out of
these conversations earlier I and this
is before we established the rules it's
like a licking or look at that guy in
the checkerboard suit just just giving
that other cousin third-degree I was
like you're taking these conversations
too long and it's because having a blast
nope and no to clarify cuz I cuz I know
how this the dynamic of this whole thing
works the comments gonna be like why is
rep picking on link the way he wants to
do the party I think that you also need
to take some responsibility you I so it
you agree with this yeah I agree their
lives the lessons that it became an
inconvenience for the people that you
were talking yeah that's what I'm saying
you became an inconvenience to those
people and you don't want to be an
inconvenience to those people in the
same way that we wouldn't want somebody
to do that to us but again no at this
point no one was like everybody was
super nice it wasn't like we were
ruining relationships or anything like
that he may be on the show it's still
great
I wasn't my man did you notice his eyes
like his eyes were deep he's dark pools
I have the tiger man it's like you could
tell that there was something that you
normally see in people's eyes that was
not in his eyes no fear that allowed him
not to climb a mountain with nothing not
a hint of fear this man could no matter
what could have happened no matter who
would have come in there
he this man cannot be afraid at one
point I asked him I was like if they've
analyzed your brain right because I knew
there was a documentary he was there
because it was a documentary about him
that was a that was at regular theaters
yeah okay so then I'm still flying
pretty high but we do have terms of like
confident we did have a little talk
though after that yeah yeah I was like
you know listen you know let's not spend
so much time but still at this point two
links credit I still wasn't I didn't say
let's switch roles I didn't say that I
didn't say let me start the
conversations I was like no you still be
the one to start the conversation Stevie
and I will come in we'll have a great
conversation will end in a good place
and then we go to let's just yeah be a
little look quicker and I'm like more
efficient okay I'm you know I'm
teachable right I'm open to a teachable
moment
I wanna I want to learn I want to I want
to make the best of this so we go to the
bar we grab us a drink
we actually got a drink and then I turn
around and I was like that guy over
there he's talking to that girl that he
obviously came with he's like wearing a
sweater yeah he's got black hair dark
brown dark brown curly hair beard beard
that guy is a rapper that guy is a
little Dicky little Dicky little Dicky
is a very he's a hilarious rapper this
is me talking to you and Stevie I don't
know if you knew him at the time of
course anyone okay
skilled skilled lyricist and as well
yeah so milia with his work and a fan so
I'm like I'm gonna talk to him
and also still we're like right we're
not at like some places that we will
eventually get into terms of like names
that everyone will know which is where
this conversation is going are you bit
with some I'm gonna go talk to little
Dicky and I guess since I went ahead I
should tell what happened before he got
there I would love to hear you jump in
when you remember when you showed up but
let's see how did this go I go up to him
and I'm like
hey how's it going
Nona you said what did I say I've told
you I did you said exactly what I would
like to introduce hey I'd like to
introduce myself I'm link and then it
was it was kind of loud there was music
playing I was shaking his hand I put my
head down to put my ear towards his
mouth to hear his response and he said
hey man I'm and he said her name he said
a name right and then I looked up and
again I was just as close to I could
have did the thumb pinkie touch with her
and so what you were thinking there
because that ruins the punchline I said
I thought you were little dickie and
then he said I am and I said well I know
he was like that's you know that's not
that's not my real name and then he
proceeded to say hey jay-z he brought up
jay-z he said I was there by this point
he said jay-z's name is not jay-z right
and I was like well I I know that I was
just yeah I mean I understand that's not
your name but I just didn't know if it
was you because here's what happened
it wasn't that I thought his name was
little Dickey for inre and he was going
to introduce himself that way it's that
when I got that close to little Dickey
for the very first time in my life and
like I'm looking up and I could have you
know I could have I could have kissed
him on the nose when I was that close I
immediately was overwhelmed with the
thought this is not a little dick
this is just some guy some guy that
looks a lot like a little Dickie at the
GQ party but again when you get that
close to somebody you can see the pores
in their skin you've ever seen that you
start to look a little dickie they look
a little more real than any other way
they've been presented on any screen and
so at that moment I was just thinking
I don't want to have a conversation with
this guy thinking he's a little Dicky
but it turns out he's not I don't want
to invest that amount of time cuz that's
gonna get awkward so instead of making
this awkward having an awkward
conversation is if I think he's a rapper
that he's not I'm just gonna say more
awkward than I ever could possibly other
than that I thought you were little
Dicky I am which you had you realized
that and do in avoiding awkwardness you
stepped into the one of the most awkward
conversations you had the probably the
most you had it that night my time on
the planet and cuz it didn't end there
because then I was like trying I was
like oh here's here's my friends rent
and Stevie and hopefully they can help
rescue me from this awkward moment I've
created again I thought I'll just
acknowledge that I've done this and then
at that point he he turned to me and he
said you're doing great
which side note if you ever hear that in
the conversation it doesn't mean you're
doing great and I'm not I'm just saying
what happened I'm not trying to paint
I'll say or a big big no here's the deal
I'll say that I actually think he is
very nice guy I think he was trying he
was trying to make it funny because what
was happening was so awkward I think he
was just trying to make it funny and you
know what - it was very funny it was
funny and you know what he he deserves
no hate for that response because I
don't think he was being mean I think he
was trying to play it off yeah it was in
it and it was funny from his perspective
we talked about but okay so I don't know
there's a lot of lessons learned in this
situation I mean obviously well it got
worse after that because I was talking
to him I was like you talk to him a
little bit and like you and Stevie were
kind of embarrassed for me and I get
that and then I was like hey man your
songs are hilarious like they actually
played one of them in the Oh in my gym
forgot about this like they were playing
one in the gym and I was just like
busting out laughing and I was like you
were violating that other rule again
yeah I talked about you were talking
about your personal touch your very
personal toughs fanboying over his song
and then I was like I was like yeah man
I'm in there laughing I'm like you're
helping me get fit like this and then I
pointed in my body I'm like this is for
you yeah and I was like no I well I
don't mean I don't mean this is for you
I meant this is because of you like me
being this fit is because I was just
trying to make a joke and I played my
song your song in my gym here's the
thing if but this is for you this you
want at this point a little Dicky should
have said you know what I'm not a little
Dicky yeah you know like that's actually
what he should have said because it
would have entered the covers and it's
interesting because do you remember a
guy came over my left shoulder and said
hey man and he leaned into his ear and
he was like I really blob of blood and
then little Dicky was like thanks man
and then the guy walked off and then I
said to him I was like done out I should
run now that's what I should have done I
told him that yeah well but there was no
recovery it was I was like a puddle well
okay but but there's a couple things
okay because we're just more we got to
get to more stuff there's better stories
than this believe it or not
that's it I'm done the the first thing
that I said tell a fan I did I don't
think that you should say I would like
to introduce myself my name is link
because yeah I think that you should
just not saying you shouldn't introduce
yourself but you you began the
conversation in a way that was like I
know that you have no idea who I am and
I'm just coming at you from this just
I'm just a fan versus just like hey I'm
link you could have just said hey give
them a little bit of a sliver a doubt
that they might know who you are or have
worked with you before or should know
who you are I personally like to go with
good to see you because that's not
untrue not again but it's good to see
you good to see you good to see you good
to see you but then you can then you say
I'm Rhett you can't do but I'm reading
I'm reading this the situation but in
these situations I came in so late that
it was just it was that was the plan and
then it was just oh we were just talking
about what you had talked about so and
again you already know the whole thing
about like if you think somebody's that
person and just go with it until you
find another
way out of the conversation other than
sudden suddenly doubting in the middle
of a C's name is not jay-z so after the
turns so after that happened we began to
talk about how what we had done is we
had created an incredible air biscuit
it's like yeah this stories that were
being generated by your interactions
with people were so entertaining to me
that I was I was just having a great
time being
Steve and I both being blown away at how
South the the conversations were going
well we talked to Bo Burnham after that
and that was a great conversation but it
was we reminisced about the first time
we met in 2008 yeah you've had it had a
good little conversation saw him later
made eye contact and then we went
different directions because we had
already had our conversation right but
then we're rolling around the party and
one of the things this is another sort
of principle that you see in these
industry parties is that the
recognizable faces begin to thin out
very quickly right after you know I
don't know if the party starts at nine
o'clock
well then by like 10:30 at the latest
anybody that you would recognize that
celebre they're gone and now it's just
the industry people who just want to
have a party who are there and so I got
in there one picture and they're out
again we do not see ourselves as
celebrities we we're at the party to
kind of establish ourselves in that way
but that's not how we think about
ourselves and so we have to have this
thing where it's like it kicks in and
we're like ah you know what everybody
else who's supposed to be famous has
left so we should probably leave to like
it's literally that level of reasoning
it's not cool in any way we might let's
get one more drink or let's get some
more of that food I want another one of
those cake pops
you know me I'm going for the food and
as we're contemplating that there's like
a line of people and I turn around I
look over my shoulder Michael B Jordan
is walking by and I'm like without I'm
like he's moot he's in motion he's going
towards the exit this is if I'm gonna
meet Michael B Jordan or if you're gonna
meet him this is the moment so I wheeled
around and I was like hey I'd like to
introduce myself
Emily
hadn't gotten over that yet he's like
hey man he never stopped by the way I
watched he never stopped moving we can
smart as I rotate it trying to follow
Michael B Jordan muscular do shorter
than me though and he said he was like I
was like congratulations on everything
yeah that wasn't bad that's pretty good
so good now and then then he kept moving
and then as I turn back around a look at
you guys I got hit in the shoulder yep
by a guy bodyguard number one who was
following Michael B Jordan and then as I
continued to turn around I got hit in
the shoulder buddy or another guy's
shoulder yeah and then if my memory
serves me correctly I saw it happen four
times so you can hit four times I felt
the need to make physical contact with
my shoulder just to let me know hey dude
you just talked to my employer as he was
exiting and I just want my presence to
be felt and I happened four times in
rapid succession yeah it didn't hurt it
wasn't aggressive it wasn't just one of
us stay I'm not gonna press any charges
the way things work it's just the way
things work yeah he had some bodyguards
I don't think anybody else there have
bodyguards but then right before we
leave we're like we gotta make one last
wait is there a section of the party
that we missed because again we're
looking it's make one more round I mean
I'm looking at like the previous year's
pictures from this party and like
Rihanna was there and of course I'm
thinking well if I mean how much I if I
meet Rihanna I gotta talk to her about
how you know I have a crush the Internet
I think you might would intend to
introduce yourself yeah I might I would
have said my name I would like to
introduce myself and I wouldn't have
carried her but so we're thinking we're
gonna meet somebody like that and so we
we we take one last little stroll there
if there's this little area outside that
we hadn't seen yet and it was I think it
was like the smoking section it was a
porch Stevie was like oh there's a porch
out there and then she like grabs arms
she was like it's not a secret section
it's been the smoking section how long
all the coolest celebrities are in the
smoking section which don't smoke
celebrities it's not good for you
but we not everybody was smoking in the
smoking
it's what it was small and we walked out
there and of course it's dwindling by
this point and I didn't see anybody and
we're standing out there and then all of
a sudden John Mayer John Mayer John
Mayer now not 40 year old white guys I
think it's important we like John Mayer
I think it's important for me to tell
this one from my perspective are there
people who don't there are people who
like hate John Mayer so if like if we're
talking about how we like gushing over
John Mayer that'd be like what you know
you're in poor taste or something I
don't know okay let's just set the
record straight about John Mayer
his most recent albums when he went a
little bit country that is his best work
if you disagree with that you are wrong
he's an incredible musician he's
incredible songwriter he's an incredible
lyricist he's an incredible guitar
player like virtuoso guitar player now
he may have made some weird personal
choices and statements in the past and
I'm not defending that and I and I'm not
even referencing that but he is an
incredible musician and we both love his
music and so this was an important
moment for us when we saw John Mayer so
we're standing you know I could probably
throw a rock hard enough to kill him
from that distance I don't know I'm just
trying to I don't want to do that I'm
just saying I love the way they kind of
say yes did you like the paint the
physical space picture I was close I was
talking to him and had my finger on my
nose if I had a if I had a a rock about
the size of a fist I could probably kill
but based on the way that you had
behaved throughout the night this at
this point I wasn't even having to do it
Stevie was in charge at this point she
said you cannot talk to him you cannot
talk to John
okay so yeah and we were saying I'm like
you know what I you know you're right
I'm not gonna talk to him he was
standing next to it we the three of us
were in our little group and he was in a
group of like two or three people
talking to them
yeah and we're you know close enough to
kill him with a rock and at that point
we're saying like you can't talk to him
because it's just gonna be super awkward
but then he begins to leave and that
exit involves walking past us walking
behind me and actually closest to you so
you did the Michael B Jordan move and
you turn well yeah cuz and I've been
saying I'm not gonna tell I'm Allah I'll
play nice I'm not gonna we'll wait for
another opportunity there'll be another
time to meet John Mayer I'm not gonna I
got a I got a gather myself there'll be
another party but then when he started
exiting and he was right behind me I was
like psych I gotta meet him you know
I've wheeled around and you said hey
John what was your middle statement cuz
it's your last statement that's you were
like couldn't Congrats
I I think I was like big fan you said
something that wasn't a specific as big
fan and I've told the story to a bunch
of people I can't but the the last part
was in any count he didn't see it
because like hey man yeah thanks but he
was not anyways exiting but you said I
love you
yeah I did
I said I told him that I loved you and
but and you didn't intend that when you
know who could tell by the way you start
it was like hey I love you it's changed
and I love you right I love well he was
walking away so fast no no you said hey
John nice work I love you yeah that's it
that is exactly what you said to John
Mayer hey John nice work he said thanks
man thanks he kept walking my I love you
and then he was gone but from my
perspective from like inside of my brain
which you know is a weird place you
should buy a ticket it's worth the wait
I think I was gonna say somewhat I love
your work that could have worked but he
was gone so it was just I love you
you're no you said I love you you're
trying you're facing him now you're
trying to save it
yeah you said I love you but you know
what I do love him and that's great and
I'm sure you know what John doesn't care
he doesn't remember you know it wasn't a
memorable exchange now little dickie I
think might remember yeah he probably
does I feel the need to take a moment to
speak directly to normal he told us what
is his name his name is David Dave David
bird he introduced themselves Dave Dave
I know your name's not little Dickie I
know that I put you in an awkward
position
and I even know that in telling our
story that it might paint you as the bad
guy but I want to go on record and say
that you did the best you could you even
brought some humor into it which I fully
appreciate I'm still a fan you note you
didn't do anything wrong
so you have no need to apologize and no
need for me to let you off the hook even
though I'm doing it I look forward to
seeing you again where we can have a
normal conversation and let's just go
from there
can we start over can I have a do-over
sure thanks Dave
now what so John just have a moment with
you
he's not watching I love you there's no
chance that's it that's all I wanted to
say to you so as we sew on the way home
that night we started kind of
establishing John it's got a big noggin
well all the greats do all the greats do
all the great songwriters close like
that big it's a it's like twice as big
as yours yeah I don't know it's not
twice as big I mean it's probably 20%
bigger yeah in a good way as we
discussed the rules we've kind of been
through a few of them you know get out
of the conversation earlier don't talk
about something don't talk about the
thing that they're known for talk about
something tangential or just ask what
are you working on now don't assume that
they don't know who you are just talk to
them like you're picking up a
conversation don't tell them you love
them don't be a don't be a fanboy and
there's a certain level of celebrity and
I think Michael B Jordan and John Mayer
both fit this bill that there's just
really no circumstances that you should
talk to them I there's very few thinkers
very can't accept that there's very few
ends to to that conversation going the
way that she that you would want I think
it's typically typically gonna be you're
gonna be talking to somebody who then
has a connection or something like that
it now you've got a gate I think you're
gonna get more of a thrill and you're
gonna get better stories I think mamrie
Hart
met Reese Witherspoon at a party and
they're like best friends now she's so
much better with people well that's for
sure I think if we need to we need to
hire her to consult
me but I'm just gonna go to parties with
mamrie
but again of course I kind of need to be
invited again I am I'm grateful I'm
grateful that you took the initiative
I'm grateful I'm grateful that we have
these stories these stories are probably
in one sense more strategic and of more
value than the relationship that we
could have had with those people yes
that we will never have with those
people now but you know what we made
Alex Honnold might be on the show at
some point don't forget we talked to
Terry Crews he knew who we are and he
gave us like a motivational speech that
same night and let me say I initiated
the conversation because we had seen him
the night but no no and that's what I'm
saying I'm time outlining the
differences and I'm not saying it's I
think that in the setting you can talk
to Terry you're you're better at these
things so what I'm saying is that I will
talk to anybody if I've got something if
I've got a point of contact and so we we
had seen him at the I'm not in he's by
the way we talked about this before
nicest guy on the planet
Terry Crews nicest guy on the planet
right and actually inna Sun watch the
show he was incredible but we took these
rules and we said the next time we go to
a party yeah we're going to apply some
of these rules and so we got invited to
the HBO Golden Globes afterparty
and I was coming back from first of all
you is you know we were told I think
it's you probably could even have to
have a tux but like you know technically
black-tie we didn't have tuxes I was in
Mexico at the time and I was going to
get back get fitted for a tux because
the rest don't wear something off the
rack because they don't make things that
fit me okay so I have to get things
fitted I have to get things tailored if
they were they're gonna look halfway
decent and so I was gonna have to get
off the plane come here to the office
get fitted for a tux and then
immediately get into a car and go to
this party which is what happened and I
was actually a little bit late because
there was a flight delay
so we're hit we're going down and
apparently all the parties after the
Golden Globes are at the hotel the
Beverly Hilton where the where the
Golden Globes are held and they're all
in these little areas so you got Netflix
and Amazon and Hulu or whatever in HBO
so there's like fight there's like six
party so I'm like big significant
parties and they're all in the same
place and so because the traffic would
be so crazy to this little hotel they
have a shuttle service yeah where you
meet off-site at like a parking area and
you get into these shuttles yeah we were
told to over to the location as shuttles
right then the shuttle will take you to
the party and then you you know bring
your ID so you can you know because
there's a list there's a list right so
we get to we get to the shuttle area and
we see just a bunch of shuttles lined up
and we go to the first one and it's
closed and it's full we go to the second
one is closed and it's full we go to the
third one the doors open what do we do
we go on the shuttle yeah go up in the
shuttle and lo and behold the shuttles
full except for two seats come on how
many of us are there two two perfect
math just the two of us so we just we
sat down we sit down and then we begin
to have a conversation with a woman
who's sitting next to us and this
conversation concerns me a little bit
you know as the one who tends to worry a
little bit more and try to figure out if
we're doing the right thing yeah I was
feeling great you were just like we're
all [ __ ]
we're on the shuttle that's great and I
was like but something doesn't seem
right about this because we didn't talk
to anybody
we just got on the shuttle and then we
talked and she the woman was not going
to the HBO party and she was actually
but but I think she was already under
the influence of something okay you know
there was something going on there
because it was not a clear communication
from her and I just when I was I didn't
want to seem uncool but I was just like
is this going to the HBO party and she
was like well it goes to all the parties
and then I'm like what do you mean is it
like a we gonna be dropped off at
different parties we didn't know that
all the parties were at the same place
we had no we knew nothing I'm beginning
to think we should get off of the
shuttle and go and like tell people hey
we don't we don't know what we want to
go to the HBO party we don't belong here
is what it sounded like to me so I'm
like no
staying put on the shuttle I'm not gonna
admit defeat in front of everybody on
this shuttle was by having a walk of
shame stay tuned to what actually
happens so James so we then the shuttle
starts moving so we don't you later that
we're like arguing with each other under
our breath and I'm like trying to calm
Rhett down like and then sigh well the
shuttles moving is nothing we can do now
we finally get over there to the Beverly
Hilton which was like half a mile away
it wasn't even that far they let us off
and then they're like a lot of security
people on the red carpet their
wristbands wristbands I'm and everyone
on the shuttle has a wristband except
you know who the two guys who just
walked onto the shuttle randomly because
apparently there was a whole thing at
the parking place where you had to get
checked in and get your wristbands so
you could get into the hole there were
no signs there was no whirring yeah two
artists in our defense no one told us
this and there was other people who were
like oh I did we heard directly here cuz
I didn't want to get on that shuttle and
I don't have a wristband either so then
this woman's like taking down names and
going going
she's with HBO and she's like going to
get wristbands and it okay now at this
point talk about being a little bit
embarrassed if you're talking about when
trying to say face on but for the
shuttle when ended up happening is
everyone's getting off these shuttles
and just walking straight past security
and you and I and some real estate
people yeah they said that they were a
real estate are all standing out there
obviously fans yeah not able to get in
and we look like two guys that just
dressed up and walked and we're just
hoping we could you know slide by
security like the old like the Grammy
video we did yours because that does
happen there are people like lurking and
trying to look like they belong and just
kidding Jeff Bridges was leaving all
kinds of people were coming and going
all kinds of a very recognizable actor
Steven route watch behind you I know and
then you didn't tell me until he was
already gone because I didn't want you
and you should thank me for this I
didn't want you to meet your favorite
character actor Steven root on the
outside of a party where it's seen
without a wristband yeah you didn't want
do that either nope so thank me I'm not
ready to do that because he wasn't in
the party Brett he wasn't in our party
yeah but he would've been like you come
in and you would've been like as soon as
I get a wristband oh he's one of those
guys
right mm-hmm well but we may have ended
up faring better than if we hadn't have
gotten on the show I think we because it
did take about 30 minutes of I was kind
of frantically texting our PR people
because I thought that we were not gonna
get in at that point we got to go back
to home base and it was gonna set us
back forever but eventually we did get
somebody came out and gave us wristbands
and then we were able to check in and it
did take about 30 minutes and a lot of
people walking by but we have a we have
reason to believe that if we had have
gone all the way to the back of the line
and checked in the right way we probably
would've gotten to the party at like an
hour and a half later it was oh yes how
late this thing was but then we go in so
we got in earlier but we got in and this
party was different it's bigger
you could get plates full of food at
this party and there were seats they
were like tables like round tables it
was much more laid-back it was more like
a dinner party well not a dinner party
but a party where you could eat dinner
yeah yeah a party we can you dinner but
not a dinner party where everybody's
seated and someone gives a speech that's
not it but I would say the percentage of
really famous people was lower
percentage of really famous people but a
lot of just like I know that guy from
that movie I know that guy from that
show but yeah I don't know his name and
you probably wouldn't either but you'd
recognize him it was like a lot of those
people and then a lot of Industry people
and it was a it was a much larger
parties but I mean terms of space and in
terms of attendance we have some good
conversations with people who you know
it's again it's good to have industry
conversations meet producers and all
this type of stuff so it's like and and
a number of those people talk to us
because they knew who we were sometimes
because their kids know who we were but
hey that's a good end well I'll take it
any way I can get it and we also well we
had a couple of people that we wanted to
talk to
right is HBO party so we we thought that
mark and Jay Duplass would be there
right we both finished reading their
book yep
fans of theirs we think I'd like to have
a conversation we'd like to talk to
those guys right because we just think
that just relate to their race their
relationship similar backgrounds and
similar philosophies and but I don't
they weren't there as far as they could
have been there and maybe we missed him
but we didn't see them so because I was
trying to and maybe I pushed it too far
in my direction which I was like let's
talk to people that we've got a reason
to talk to that doesn't mean we have to
know them but like let's initiate a
conversation and there's like an in like
with those guys it would have been like
hey we just read your book and first of
all that would mean something them
because we're not talking about room 104
or whatever everybody else is talking
about we're talking about this thing
that like oh pet project you guys like
the book yeah we just listen to it
here's all these parallels that are
really interesting between us and you
guys and you were prepped for that I was
ready for that conversation but that
didn't happen
we saw Pete Holmes who had been on good
mythical morning let's call him a friend
of the show friend of the show and out
of convert you've met his wife for the
first time had a great conversation with
Pete he actually said the same basically
the same thing is like took us forever
to get into this party and I'm glad I
ran into you guys because getting it you
know having a conversation that I want
to be in is actually makes it worth it
that felt great you know because he's
thinking the same thing he's got a show
on HBO and he's thinking the same thing
like Who am I gonna talk to her this
thing but let's not make it out to be
like we have to have certain types of
interactions at a party to feel good
about ourselves because earlier you
established we don't need that well but
I'm not the one that tries to walk with
him what is your what is your goal and
all the conversations that you try to
initiate you're just trying to have a
good time move and shake I mean there is
a business to this but it's not is what
I don't need to feel good about myself
and I don't think you do either but I'm
just saying that it sounded like it in
that moment where it's like oh it felt
good for somebody to say they wanted to
talk to us and it did feel good one but
it's it's just a weird it's a weird
environment where like maybe this is
this is kind of true of La in general
is that is people trying to get
themselves noticed or get their project
accomplished or to like to make their
way and so it's you know industry
parties our industry parties there to in
there to work you know it's not like a
friend party like you said we're like
yeah you may there may be a bunch of
celebrities at a party and boy wouldn't
that be interesting but they're there
because they're friends like that's not
an industry party well because I mean
with the gotta get something done well
because one of the things that we're
that we're thinking about just you know
strategically creatively I don't know
one of the things that we've learned is
getting really qualified people to help
you make things into make things happen
is that's what we want to do right I
mean that's that's the reason that we're
doing what we do today is because at
some point we figured out oh you know
what really works is getting people who
can do things better than we can to do
those things and that's why we have a
team now but the same thing applies to
well who are you gonna work with who
you're gonna collaborate with on this
project who's gonna who's gonna help
write it produce it who's gonna act in
it that kind of thing and things that we
want to do and so you want to have those
connections so that when you say here's
the idea will you help make it happen
and would you like to be in it to an
actor or whatever it's like oh yeah we
yeah I do because either I saw you at
that party and I saw you guys on the red
carpet and then I look you know it these
little touch points matter if you write
play that game but it's all unspoken I
don't think maybe there is a booklet or
something but and maybe I could have
saved a lot of heartache inside step 2 a
fun podcast though by reading it I don't
think that any damage has been done no
let me let me just clarify that I didn't
say they had I think that even in the
most even the most embarrassing
interaction that you had with with mr.
David Byrne little Dicky is what they
call him he's a rap name I call him Dave
even that conversation
the chances of us working with little
dickie actually went up because of the
interaction now there are interactions
where the chances would have gone down
right the chances would have gone down
it they were really they were at a
tipping they were right there in a real
gray area for a second there yeah glad I
didn't have a rock right John Mayer
would have been horrible but I do think
that the most important thing is just
beginning the conversation but I do
think that we now know how to be a tad
more strategic I think that there were
no mishaps at the Golden Globe party
except for the shuttle thing which I
think ended up being great we got there
earlier so I don't I don't think I have
any demerits no lessons learned about
the HBO party yeah I can't I can't think
of any any lessons learned at the Golden
Globes party and I got a tux out of it
well I had I mean I bought it well I
tell you one lesson we learned we
actually applied it after you go through
the red carpet and get your pictures
taken by the professional photographers
you go back to the red carpet at the end
of the night and there will be people
taking their pictures with our iPhones
yeah you get one of them to take a
picture of you with your phone yeah and
that will allow you to have a picture on
your camera roll that isn't you don't
have to wait to the next day to get some
Getty image or something like that it's
like the picture that we posted was just
a picture from the phone that's a little
hack that's a little insider tip there
it is so we're going to get so now next
time we post photos from the next thing
we go to you're gonna be thinking man
that's a lot more complicated than I
thought it was there's lots of ins and
outs yeah so thanks for hanging out with
us thanks for for learning along with us
because I mean let's be clear we both
learned a lot
right I learned so much watching you so
much yeah man I might I'm a teacher man
I'm a teacher in action right you what
not to do you teach by example you too
you teach by bad example it is it is a
it is a form of teaching I omit it it is
fun I'm enjoying myself and Steven root
I'm coming for you oh gosh
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]